النتنياهو يرد على الحوثيين بعد ان اعلنوا
حصار تلبيب دعوه المانيه عاجله للعبري
فريق عسكري بريطاني يعمل على اعداد سلطه
القطاع صحف عبريه تكشف خسائر تلابيب
البشريه في حربها والفصائل تعلن عن شرط
وحيد لاعاده الاسرى لديها الجيش العبري
يعترف بفشل عمليه مهمه في القطاع اختفاء
طائره امريكيه في سماء اليابان طن وطوكيو
وسول تتخذن تدابير جديده تجاه كوريا
الشماليه بريطانيا تكشف عن شكو جوهريه
لاوكرانيا كابوس الرئيس الاوكراني بدا
يتحقق وموسكو تحدد شروط السلام الدائم في
اوكرانيا اليمن يخنق
تلبيب لم يكتفي الحوثيون بتهديد السفن
الاسرائيليه في البحر الاحمر بل لهم
يعلنون تصعيدا جديدا من نوع اخر يفرض
حصارا خانقا على تل هنا اعلن الناطق
العسكري باسم الحوثيين في اليمن العميد
يحيى سريع انهم قرروا منع مرور السفن
المتجهه الى تلبيب اذا لم يتم ادخال
الغذاء والدواء الى القطاع مؤكدا ان اي
سفينه تتجه الى تلبيب من اي جنسيه كانت
ستكون هدفا مشروعا لهم ليرد النتنياهو
بانه اخبر الرئيس الامريكي والمستشار
الالماني ان تلبيب ستتصرف عسكريا ان لم
تتخذ اجراءات ضد الحوثيين ضيف مستشار
الامن القومي العبري ابلغنا امريكا اننا
سنتحرك ضد الحوثيين اذا لم يتحرك العالم
في بريطانيا قال وزير الدفاع جراند شامس
ان فريقا عسكريا بريطانيا يعمل على اعداد
السلطه الفلسطينيه لتولي اداره القطاع بعد
انتهاء الحرب حسب ما نقلت صحيفه التايمز
البريطانيه وقال شامس ان فريق الدعم
البريطاني موجود في رام الله منذ اكثر من
عر سنوات من جانبه دعى المتحدث باسم
الحكومه الالمانيه سيبستيان فشر تل ابيب
الى الامتثال للقانون الانساني الدولي
وحمايه السكان المدنيين في القطاع اما في
امريكا فكشف مسؤولان امريكيان ان اداره
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن طلبت من
الكونجرس الموافقه على بيع 45 الف قذيفه
لدبابات ميركافا العبريه بحسب رويترز فيما
افاد مسؤول دفاعي عبري كبير لموقع اكسيوس
بان تل ابيب تتوقع انهاء عمليتها العسكريه
في مدينه يونس جنوب القطاع خلال ثلاثه الى
اربعه اسابيع ليصرح القيادي في الفصائل
اسامه حمدان ان الفيتو الامريكي يمنح تل
ابيب الضوء الاخضر لاستمرار الهجوم على
القطاع ويؤكد ان الاداره الامريكيه متورطه
مضيفا ان تل ابيب لن تستعيد اسرها
المتبقين الا اذا توقف الهجوم على القطاع
على ارض الميدان كشفت صحيفه يد ع ت احرنوت
حجم خسائر جيش العبريين في القطاع وذلك ب
5000 مصاب و 2000 اصيبوا باعاقه واضافت ان
قسم اعاده التاهيل بوزاره الدفاع يستقبل
يوميا 60 جريحا ومعظم الاصابات خطره هنا
اعلنت الفصائل ان مقاتليها دمروا 21 اليه
في جميع محاور القتال بالقطاع خلال 24
ساعه مع تواصل القصف العبري على الاحياء
الشرقيه من مدينه خانيونس لتطلق الفصائل
رشقات صاروخيه كثيفه على تل اذيب الكبرى
بحسب قناه الجزيره هنا ك اعترف الجيش
العبري بفشل عمليه تحرير ل محتجز في
القطاع وقال الجيش في بيان نشره عبر حسابه
على منصه اكس ان جنديين عبريين اصيبا
بجروح خطره خلال تلك العمليه لانقاذ رهائن
لدى الفصائل على الحدود اللبنانيه اعلن
الجيش العبري ان قواتي رصدت خلال ساعات
الليل عددا من عمليات اطلاق النار من داخل
الاراضي اللبنانيه باتجاه تل ابيب وانه
يرد باستهداف مصادر اطلاق النار لتعلن
مقاومه لبنان ان مقاتليها استهدفوا تجمعين
لجنود عبريين في محيط موقعي المطل وراميه
قباله الحدود الجنوبيه للبنان وحققوا
اصابات مباشره في
[موسيقى]
الاستهدافية
بعيدا عن حرب القطاع ذكرت هيئه الاذاعه
والتلفزيون اليابانيه nh اش كي ان مسيره
امريكيه اختفت خلال تدريبات في قاعده
بمقاطعه شيزوكا بينما اتفقت الولايات
المتحده وكوريا الجنوبيه واليابان على
اتخاذ تدابير جديده لمواجهه كوريا
الشماليه في الفضاء الالكتروني والرد على
اطلاق بيونج يانج المستمر للصواريخ
البالستيه بحسب وكاله
رويترز روسيا تضع شروط وط
السلام بعد صمت طويل لقد حان الوقت لتقول
كوريا الشماليه كلمتها بشان الحرب في
اوكرانيا هنا قالت وكاله الانباء المركزيه
الكوريه الشماليه ان المساعده المقدمه
لاوكرانيا عمل انتحاري وجريمه حرب تؤدي
الى اطاله امد النزاع بالعوده الى
اوكرانيا افادت صحيفه تامز البريطانيه بان
الجيش الاوكراني يشكو من نوعيه وكميه
القذائف التي يتلقاها من جميع انحاء
العالم حيث تقول كيف انه كان لديها ذخيره
اكثر بعشر مرات في الصيف وذات نوعيه افضل
اما الان فهم يجلبون لها قذائف من جميع
انحاء العالم ذات نوعيات مختلفه وقليله
جدا هناك رجحت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال
استنادا لتقييمات دبلوماسيين غربيين
واستراتيجي عسكريين ان اوكرانيا لن تكون
قادره على شن هجوم مضاد كبير قبل عام
2025 واش شارت الصحيفه الى ان اوكرانيا
ستحتاج الى وقت للتعافي فيما اكدت صحيفه
اندبندنت انه سيتعين على الرئيس الاوكراني
فلاديمير زيلينسكي التخلي عن الارض مقابل
السلام تفاديا لخسائر افدح رغم ان ذلك
سيعني هزيمه اوكرانيا والولايات المتحده
واوروبا لتحدد موسكو من جانبها شروط
السلام الدائم في اوكرانيا باعلان
المتحدثه باسم وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه
ماريا زاخاروفا ان سلامه الدائمه في
اوكرانيا يكون ممكنا الا اذا توقف الغرب
عن نقل الاسلحه اليها وتقبل الواقع
الاقليمي الجديد اما صحيفه فاينانشال
تايمز البريطانيه فذكرت ان كابوسا
زيلينسكي بشان وقف الدعم من الحلفاء
الغربيين بدا يتحقق واوضحت الصحيفه ان
مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي رفض المحاوله
الاخيره للبيت الابيض لتمرير قانون الدعم
المالي لاوكرانيا بمبلغ 60 مليار دولار
كما ان مساله تخصيص المفوضيه الاوروبيه
لمبلغ 50 مليار يورو لدعم ميزانيه كيف على
مدى السنوات الاربع المقبله معلقه ايضا
على المحك في الصين ذكرت صحيفه جلوبال
تايمز انه بما ان الهجوم المضاد الجديد
غير مرجح بسبب التكاليف الماليه والماديه
والاستراتيجيه الضخمه فمن الممكن ان تفتح
نافذه لاستئناف مفاوضات السلام قريبا بين
موسكو وكييف بشان المعارك اعلنت القوات
الروسيه انها تمكنت من السيطره على نقطه
تمركز تابعه لقوات كيف والقضاء على مسلحين
تابعين للقوات الاوكرانيه يرتدون ملابس
عليها اشارات امريكيه فيما اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه تكبيد الجيش الاوكراني
اكثر من
625 قتيلا وجريحا واسقاط 11 مسيره اطلقتها
قوات كيف على مختلف المحاور خلال 24
ساعه
[موسيقى]
ا